thanks for the opportunity um i'm very
happy to be here to share some quick
thoughts on our president president
carter's comments in particular about
hong kong i i was a little bit surprised
that you see you know a flood of
comments and questions
coming from hong kong in particular on
the
the ongoing protests i mean that's quite
a
relief to me uh you know to see the
whole world certainly has a lot of
attention some hong kong um you know
hong kong shouldn't be a forgotten child
uh after the handover back to 1997.
so i think i i intended to agree that uh
jimmy carter's approach to sort of
resolve the situation in hong kong he
mentioned probably uh you know the
students should negotiate with the
government uh you know for a more uh
long-term uh solution which is to uh you
know how to get the 1200
nominators uh to be democratic
uh elected that is a very good
suggestion but on the other side i feel
you know perhaps
president carter sort of underestimates
the complexity of the situation
one thing we all know is
beijing just doesn't want to see
any uncertainty
in the
situation in hong kong you know even for
the long run so if you want beijing to
back down sort of to get the nominators
to be elected for the long run basically
you open the door for the genius
universal uh uh
universal suffrage for the long run i
don't think that will be an option that
beijing beijing will take so uh he he
has a very good intention a good
suggestion but i don't think it's very
uh practical uh the other thing is about
the mutual trust i think he mentioned a
couple of times and i fully agree with i
think
on both sides p you know
people-to-people relations
on both sides and government to
government relations on both sides you
know certainly a mutual trust is one of
the very key problems that we don't see
any how you know a very realistic
solution to to solve it it's quite
interesting you know he mentioned so
many chinese students nowadays you know
studying the u.s but we have to ask
ourselves you know why we still have
such low mutual
trust between between the two countries
i mean one of the questions from the
the audience you know basically blame
the media i
to some extent that may
make some sense but the side the the
cyber war and a lot of other things even
you know the corporate on the corporate
level sort of you know the the struggles
to steal commercial secrets i mean i
agree with president carter you know a
lot of things like that happen on equal
equal basis
so it's not like you know a a one-way
solution you have to get some two-way
communications to work on that thanks
sorry about that um
i'll keep my remarks quite brief i
thought he did it i mean i hope i'm that
lucid and engaging and funny at age 90.
um i think that he was really struck a
very nice balance between um you know
striving to promote cooperation but also
recognizing that we in the united states
and china don't always see eye to eye on
whether it's taiwan or human rights um
that you know expressing differences in
a you know in a reasonable manner but
not necessarily uh getting up on a
soapbox and declaiming the other's
actions particularly when that would be
a counterproductive is a sort of a wise
i think course of action and uh
um
so i would just say that i think that
particularly with the ongoing uh
situation in hong kong i think the obama
administration by and large has has
followed i think um you know
that type of a model of um you know
sounding supportive but not necessarily
being pointedly so and i think that
that's been
you know to the extent that there can be
a compromise and to give
those in beijing a sense of security
rather than feeding into their
insecurity and the sense of nationalism
there that's a that's been i think
that's been helpful
um
i think that what i was most struck by
of course was carter himself
i kept listening um
to this historical figure
90 years old the peer of deng xiaoping
so deng xiaoping has passed on and
carter is
is still there and i was so i was
listening very attentively to the way in
which he retold that history
and then if i'm thinking forward i kept
going back in my mind the conditions
that allowed deng xiao ping and jimmy
carter in secret
and then publicly to negotiate such
important terms of this taiwan
relationship
and how
in my mind such
possibilities are impossible
for
obama
and she
so that was the kind of thing that was
going through my head i watched
i've always actually admired and
respected carter people when they said
this was a disastrous administration and
he couldn't do x y and z i actually
didn't believe it then and i still don't
believe it historically if i put
carter in the context of the presidents
of the last 50 years to me
there's some very
noteworthy achievements and um of course
if you're interested in china you're
particularly struck by what happened in
u.s china relations so i think that was
really the
the
issue that's playing in the back of my
head is that i feel the uh challenges
before
even though he said who could have we
never could have imagined the china
today in 1978.
uh the two of them could not have
imagined uh how far the two countries
have gone and how our society's
economies are so interpenetrated
but i was also thinking in a way
perhaps it was easier
for
the president-to-president kind of
diplomacy
than we have today
so i had a
a similar um
sense listening uh in part because what
what i really appreciated about uh
president carter's remarks was the sort
of broad historical perspective not just
him speaking about his work over the
past 40 years but also putting
developments in china and perspective
and you know often
in this
world dominated by uh 24-hour news media
and and a quick turnaround and messages
that have to be condensed down to to
twitter we're looking for the immediate
change and when we don't see it we think
there's no progress when in fact there's
a lot of sort of slow moving progress
that might not be quite perceptible
uh to us but to somebody who's really
been engaged for decades you know it's
very very evident so i was struck by
that um the second thing i'll say and i
and i think we'll
probably come back to i was struck
by how clear both of them were
about the centrality of the the u.s
china bilateral relationship and and
you know
they touched on pretty much every major
issue in the world you know be it peace
economic development climate change
global health
cyber security
you know energy
and the centrality of the u.s china
relationship
to that you know about 20 years ago it
was evident that if
you wanted
to achieve anything important globally
europe and the u.s had to see eye to eye
that's no longer the case it has to be
u.s
and china
shared understanding to move things
forward the last thing that struck me
and i don't know if this is something
that we might want to come back to is
that
you know this question of the
relationship of single party rule
and market capitalism and
you know despite the fact that there is
growing evidence that you know those two
things can very well
you know coexist um you know the
questions keep coming back well you know
we we couldn't have really envisioned
korea becoming democratic so so it just
got to be around the corner you know
carter i think resisted quite
effectively to this and you know and i
think
you know one of the biggest questions
for us is
you know how do we move beyond
our
presumption that um you know free
markets and and a free society have to
go together
and for me you know in a business school
the challenge of helping our students
understand
to what extent
you can have a system that is very much
dominated by markets but a political
system that
interacts with those market forces in
ways that are just completely different
from anything that that our students or
the companies that they tend to work for
uh are used to um so i was struck by
that um as well
there's a question in the front
thank you for coming tonight so during
my four years living in china there were
two things that that struck me
one was
generally the lack of trust in society
in many relationships and you know a
husband wife
a
employer a company uh citizen government
so across all different relationships so
that's one and two that there was always
kind of um
this distinction between
chinese and everyone else and that that
i don't know where that came from but it
was always kind of uh trying to
distinguish that
there's there's 1.3 billion chinese and
then there's everyone else um do you
think that those two
dynamics that
are in play in china right now can
continue if
china wants to be a world power
but first of all i'm a chinese national
um i don't feel i'm that kind of special
i guess
you know to some extent you know we see
a lot of american american movies i
think america also make you know you
guys also look very special all the
superheroes
but having said i i i get you what you
mean to say um you know i i will say on
the chinese side
the media the state media does play a
very important role in terms of
sometimes stressing and sometimes
weakening the mutual trust you know
between us and china for different
purposes and in more recent years in
particular after xi jinping came to the
stage
i i do feel pretty sad for our state
media coverage on
you know whatever happens to u.s china
relations in almost all aspects as you
just mentioned you know commercial or
political we have you know recently we
have the sort of the anti-trust campaign
in mainland china are targeting a number
of foreign companies including some
american enterprises but some people say
the anti-trust campaign is just kind of
excuse that beijing tried to you know
sort of launch a new round of attack um
to contain the expansion by u.s
companies and when the news was reported
in the in the state media you know most
chinese people can only access state
media you understand there's a huge
problem about uh you know freedom of the
press in mainland china so when they get
the news from state media they just feel
like
you guys you know american cooperates
do the wrong things and i support my
government that kind of things are not
very positive and hopeful to you know
improve the relations
so there's a question that's just come
in uh from someone bill
in new haven given his foundation's
apparent financial support from china
shouldn't we consider him a paid
lobbyist for the chinese government and
take some of his powder puff comments
about
china's today's china with a grain of
salt
so i think um the first thing we'll each
say something about that i don't think
that um
his foundation is supported by china
um it's i
he lists if you open up the carter
foundation one could check so i think
the first thing
that um bill if you're listening in or
if you're watching would be that i think
we do need to verify that it none of the
panelists thinks that's true we don't
have it in front of us right now to
double check um so we would never i
don't think i'll speak them for myself i
certainly don't consider um president
carter a paid lobbyist for the chinese
government um i think it would also draw
your attention to the piece by orville
shell in last week's new york review of
book which gives a
terrific analysis of carter's visit to
china uh which he mentions but he
doesn't talk about the substance of that
bill that visit and i think that would
also
laid arrest some of your concerns that
he could be could be a lobbyist i think
the other thing as i would just repeat
what i said what i came across was
seeing um
a former president of the united states
who was extraordinarily um
informed and had a long long career of
public service in the united states
which he has continued through
till this moment and so um he is to me
very far from a lobbyist i don't would
anyone else like to address this
question i would also add that i think
that his center and its activities in
helping monitor village elections has
actually drawn the fire of nationalists
inside china
so seeing him as too much educating the
us agenda whether that's true or not
it's another question but i don't think
that he is seen as being sort of in bed
with with the chinese at all far from it
in fact the question that you asked i
tried twitter that wasn't read out was
maybe you want to repeat it here
well i the question that i posed is how
would he respond to uh
critics inside china who see the carter
center and other ngos is trying to
weaken and westernize china
principally through this
grassroots elections but um
et cetera
right so if anything potentially the
view being the opposite that's right
so depending on where you sit so um bill
i'm not sure if you're listening
directly that was on professor jessica
weiss who was speaking about
the
views in china of the carter center
itself which is quite the reverse of
thinking them as a lobby
speaking for china on the contrast this
is the carter center and its support for
elections is seen really as a
force of change on the side of american
democracy
are there more questions coming from the
audience or people want to
speak to this question about trust i do
think um that was one of the things when
i was listening he kept coming back to
this question about trust and he was
operating at um
stratospheric levels and he was also
talking that the world in which he's
lived of you know
not only diplomatic nation to nation but
president-president issue
raises this question about how
personalized
diplomacy can be in a way that ordinary
citizens never see and it's only after
you read the transcript or hear an
interview that someone like me who's
focuses so much on structural
constraints and dynamics that the
um
not fortuitous i don't want to say that
but the power of individuals to
seal a deal can really carry forward
things at a geopolitical level um
whereas what your question was was about
trust you know at the level as you
experienced it on the ground and i i
don't think this presentation today
flew lower than ten thousand feet
i think we are really we're we're up and
we're dealing a diplomat to diplomatic
nation to nation kind of conversation
i don't know if others felt that also
you know what i'd add on the issue of
trust i can't really speak to trust
within china i trust in the institutions
but i think if you look at the bilateral
relationship you know there are several
questions about why is there so much
mistrust and you know why is it china
bashing in the u.s and why is there
america bashing in china
you know you can talk about the media
and you can talk about opportunistic
policymakers but also the reality is you
know if you take a step back
you know those are the two
dominant
powers in the world at this point right
you know the europeans
obviously have a lot of economic clout
but not the same political cloud and and
so if you if you look at who can
really be a rival to the other when it
comes to political to economic influence
in the world it's it's you know it's
china to the us and the u.s to china
so regardless of what anybody does or
anybody says you know quite structurally
you have the the ingredients for
potential mistrust and misunderstandings
because both sides are keenly aware of
their dependence on the other of their
potential vulnerability to the other
you know which means that
you know
you have to work hard
just to you know maintain a you know
certain
level of trust let alone overcome some
of those things so i think some of that
is
is inevitable it's a reflection of the
importance that each country has
in the lives of the citizens in the
other
i think also i would add that there's a
little bit of a concern that the chinese
dream or xi jinping's
use of nationalism might be seen as a
substitute for that kind of
interpersonal trust that somehow you can
unite society around sort of common
mistrust or
vigilance against an external enemy
that's i don't think that's yet set in
stone but there's a concern that it
might head in that direction and i'm
hopeful that that isn't being seen as
the strategy um but it is a it is a
concern i imagine there are some inside
china who see that as as potentially
very useful nationalism as this kind of
uniting
force as you know replacing what is
otherwise maybe might be seen as a
spiritual vacuum now we're also hearing
even last couple days using the use of
confucianism and drawing on other
traditions in china that might provide
this kind of um touchstone sort of a
cultural
a threat of unity something that chinese
can be proud of that doesn't require
rejecting the foreign although there's a
little bit of that too um so i think
this is still evolving but but
there that's if anything that's the only
connection i would see between those two
elements
um if i could i want to add some uh
comments on uh professor davis's earlier
comment about the steinshauping and
carter's relationship i think if we talk
about trust i think you know the
president to president
trust you know the mutual charge between
two persons are very critical for the
whole nation
i
i don't get maybe i'm wrong but i i
don't get the feeling that you know the
mutual trust
between xi jinping and obama could be
you know as well as you know as good as
uh carter and deng xiaoping
at least from the press coverage or you
know the information available here you
know i don't see the two gentlemen have
sort of personal chemistry you know not
yet maybe i mean dude for a period of
time i think johnson being a clean bill
clinton had sort of good chemistry and
then they can talk you know more often
even through some hotlines and the other
thing we need to think about the u.s
china relations in terms of mutual trust
is we we have to also put russia in the
context to some extent i think there are
a lot of media uh coverage and analysis
saying whether we are getting back or
not getting back and you know moving
forward to the
cold war zero you know to 2.0 era and if
that is the case and then you need to
ask yourself you know whether xi jinping
trust putting more
or you know obama you know that would be
an interesting uh observation you know
you know if we put that angle in the
context of the u.s china relations
historically going back to just his
question george and others is that i
think deng xiaoping was at a point in
his career
and what he had lived for
that he was going for broke and he was
going for history um and i don't think
xi jinping is in the same place
um it's a it's a follow-up on mr buck's
remark
about the the inevitability to some
extent of the rivalry which sounds to me
a very very reasonable assertion because
what strikes me i'm not american and
what strikes me when i hear american
leaders talking about their relation to
china is the incredible amount of
sentimentalism
whether negative or positive in it is
very striking i don't know if it's as
true on the chinese side it might be i
don't know but
it's like it's not only about trust it's
not only about like having a positive
relation it's also they want to be liked
so bad
and it's very surprising because i mean
i'm too young to know that but i don't
think there was the same amount of
feeling of like unrequited love during
the cold war with the russians so my
question is
what i mean what's going on here is it
like a special
china america thing that dates back i
don't know to the missionary age or is
it something the political culture of
america today
so yeah
if you have an idea about it
you made a reference to me but i think
the people around me are better
positioned to answer that question
so indeed i think what david talked
about was the key role that eu and the
europe played in an earlier period that
this was this strong alliance and this
this is now more complicated and you the
relationship is definitely different um
on the question of the centrality
orleans said it and people whether it's
in business or whether it's about
pollution these are the number one
number two economies the number one
number two polluters if we don't get it
straight the world will burn up i mean
so there's there's an urgency about
getting these two to agree and then the
issue about
they want the language that's used i
think always of course as you know the
us doesn't have a professional
diplomatic corps and our ambassadors our
top ambassadors our political appointees
we don't come through and come up to
international positions in the same way
as you do in europe so this creates a
very different face when the american
ambassador from any country is speaking
right he's from the winning party in the
last election and he is a major
contributor etc so he is speaking it's
there are some women also
from their own interests i think and so
it is more political sometimes it's an
extension of the campaign trail and it's
a lot of other things which
i think that maybe we're the only
country in the world certainly we're the
only
big country in the world who who puts
that face on our top diplomats right
it's not all ambassadors it's something
no the top ten right the top ten that's
right so look i mean i'd i'd say uh
including to china you know i wanna i
wanna be clear that uh you know
rivalry doesn't mean adversity to me and
rivalry
also doesn't mean that there can't be
lots of shared interests and so i i pick
up uh you know deborah point and
i don't know a whole lot about chemistry
between individuals for me the key
question is not is whether president you
and president obama have chemistry the
question is do they recognize their
shared interests
you know where do they have that
interest and that interest can lead to
collaboration that collaboration can
lead to trust and it can actually widen
the areas where you can pursue
projects of shared interest but even
though you're collaborating on projects
of shared interest there can be you know
some kind of rivalry
on the other uh to your point about
wanting to be liked uh
i'm going a little bit out of my depth
here but it seems to me that uh
you know china is uh certainly
has an image of itself as a great
civilization and i think america likes
to think of itself in much the same way
and you know it's not
a totalitarian ideology that tries to be
all-consuming but it is certainly the
kind of thing where you would say well
how can anybody not be impressed by all
of what we have uh achieved as a nation
which you know for for those of us who
are neither from china or the us who's
you know a little bit
you know uh
uh
strange at times to to to watch um so uh
you know
there's there's probably something there
as well but that perhaps is the part of
the rivalry that can even be quite
constructive right and and trying to
sort of impress people around the world
with uh progress and achievement and
commitment
i i want to say in terms of the u.s
child relationship it is certainly a
very special relationship
um
more special than anything else i can
imagine of um when xi jinping came to
power one thing he mentioned is he want
to build
a new big nation uh relationship shin
shing dak wu guanxi for the us and china
he did make some elaboration on that but
we haven't really seen like what exactly
you know the big nation relation is but
but this is for the first time xi
jinping and the shin shing dong [ __ ] is
only for us china you know uh you know
whenever he mentioned the shinxing dog
when she you know the term that's only
for u.s and china he didn't mention that
for for russia or for the for eu or you
know other you know sovereignties so
that that's one point and the other
thing is um
back to your question about you know the
online of sort of the relationship i i
pretty much agree with
professor davis i think you know except
the ambassadors i think we have to
understand u.s as a you know a political
system the society has much more higher
level you know freedom of expression so
you you have very different system you
know the congress you know the senators
you can't control
you know these people you know saying
you know i i heard from my friends
inside the foreign ministry sometimes
they get confused you know you know
sometimes obama is trying to send a good
signal and then suddenly tomorrow you
know someone else you know spoke up
something very negatively you know
totally the other way around and then
for them
all these important people are american
you know officials or congressmen or
whatever you know just titles but they
are senior american
so that kind of confusion is always in a
girl even inside the foreign ministry i
understand
i would say that this is true of i think
china's relations with a lot of
democracy obviously you know there's
only one sort of new type of great power
relationship but nonetheless if you look
at china's relations with india with
japan with taiwan and you see this kind
of this tug this push-pull kind of love
hate uh co-existing side by side is both
sides
you know recognize shared interest but
also have
these
competing interests as well as fears of
china's what china's economic and
security rise mean to their national or
perceived national interests so i think
that you see this uh you know in
the case of xi jinping's recent visit to
india where you had on the one hand huge
economic deals on the table the same
time you had a border standoff with
troops uh you know so at altitude um and
so i think if you look you know more
broadly you will see sort of elements of
this uh in many of china's foreign
relations
and then i just returned to the where we
started
my
my point that the relationship between
carter and dung
was in such a different
point
of history and
relative balance or not balance
i should have emphasized to me one of
the biggest things the biggest
difference is for dung and
carter it was really diplomacy
without very much
almost no economic actors and what was
today so obvious and with the national
committee is there's politics there but
if we talk about the web of interests
and who wasn't in that conversation but
who is in the negotiations it is the
head of every corporate 500 it was
fortune 500 as well as on the chinese
side
uh all the heads of both private and
state enterprises which now have an
autonomy
in the um chinese political system and
and they have their vested interests and
they have their voice and
that is another way in which the
conversations today have to be totally
different they're just a whole different
range of participants people constraints
and listening to that that was very much
here i felt that those voices were
nipping not nipping voices don't nip but
you know
they were there bubbling underneath this
conversation
can you hear me
recently there was
some
news regarding
president obama and
president xi jing
getting together
and
he asked the president to treat
chinese people and himself
as equal
people with respect
and it seemed that
president obama
um did not respond to that so i was
wondering i think is there
some kind of
other powers controlling president obama
i think not to respond to equal status
between the two nations
i mean i don't understand the question
the question is
that president obama i think
could not respond to
three chinese people or present
xi jinping
on equal footing
and
and i was wondering i think if
there are some
vested interests which is which are
controlling american policies
not to allow
american president to treat
um
others on equal footing
in what way any unequal footing um
taking their views i think on the world
world
negotiations like iran and things like
that
um it seems that
us's position is always trumping others
positions others
um point of views
so it's not equal feuding i think in the
world stage
u.s and one side and the rest of the
world on that side
maybe we can reframe the question to
sort of you know do you believe that
sort of american arrogance you know
thing
i think gold and for any foreign policy
there there's always uh sovereign
interests whether you want to translate
that into vested interests
and each country will speak for its
number one concern and you also and we
know in foreign policy
when
a leader speaks
very often the key audience is the
domestic audience
you have to read every single diplomatic
exchange through the lens of
the domestic
audience and for example when i
read the most
statements of coming from china
which
i
perhaps do would hope are not going to
be as hard edged
one thing i always do is turn it around
and say who who does he need to talk to
in china whatever concerns he has that
he has to address and similar in the
united states so we know that as i think
you were mentioning george we can have
all kinds of to me very extreme
statements made by congressmen in the
united states about what china is doing
or what the us should be doing and then
i'm thinking this person is running for
re-election in south carolina and that's
really what this is about he that's who
he's talking to it may seem he's talking
about a foreign issue but he is talking
to his own electorate
always i mean that's that's democratic
politics but what susan shirk has shown
very clearly and and professor weiss can
speak about because you know professor
shirks well worked so well but when she
came here to do the hume lecture she was
doing the book on public opinion in
china and so shirk has shown i think
definitively that we must read chinese
public statements and chinese
politicians as politicians who also need
to deal with public opinion and their
own domestic politics
and that means we're always reading and
re-reading what is said so on this
question of vested interest trumping
it has to be seen in this multi-leveled
uh audience
yeah i would i would agree with that i
would also say that i think that there's
actually quite as we heard from
president carter quite a lot of respect
uh for the difficulties that chinese
leaders face and their political
sensitivities at home which is important
sort of cautioning uh american leaders
from saying things you know condemning
the chinese leadership i think to the
extent that we have
people senators and others who feel sort
of morally obligated
in fact they are often championing the
chinese people
perhaps at the expense of the chinese
regime
and so in that sense i think that
there's a sense of universalism that
actually often puts americans at odds
with the chinese government but this is
i think fundamentally driven out of
respect for the chinese people rather
than uh rather than a sign of disrespect
we have two questions from harper she's
written in twice so i think we should um
share that the last one is do you think
that china and the u.s have a balanced
economic relationship
i mean
balanced in the sense that
you know each side has benefited
tremendously from the other
so
you know there is this is not a
if there is one economic relationship
that you can point to to this is true
from most economic relationships but i
think one way you can say this is
clearly not a zero-sum relationship this
is clearly an example where engagement
collaboration and trade
has created tremendous wealth on both
sides of the u.s china economic
relationships so there are aspects of
the relationship that are balanced you
know there's a trade deficit in one
direction there's uh you know flow of
investment in the other direction and so
on but overall it's clearly a
relationship that has benefited um
you know a large number of people in in
both countries even people who
um
might respond to the kind of bashing
that goes on at the same time as you
described and
you know
it is a fact that uh some of those same
voters you spoke about who probably
respond to congress people
blaming china for loss of jobs have been
enjoying um you know prices for finished
goods uh that
have
been steady in real terms and and in
fact declining and a big
reason for that is been
the
incredible uh
um competitiveness boost that is a
productivity boost that has resulted
from from china's entry into the world
economy you know people don't often
perceive it that way but it's
it's clearly a fact so
yes
i said okay perfect um so professor
davis this question is not directed to
you but it's kind of stemming off a lot
of the comments that you've made
regarding history and the way that we
look at china
so i've been i've been because i'm a
senior and i have a four day weekend
every every week i i have the luxury of
uh watching a movie on youtube um
pirated from from china
on various
topics and one of the ones that i've
been focusing on is
a movie based on ming dynasty late mean
dicey politics
from my observations of china and this
may be very naive of me
i see i see very simple there are a lot
of similarities with
kind of ming dynasty politics and what's
going on with china today in terms of
the consolidation of power under one
person at the expense of collective
leadership
and
a lot of
let's say political purgings and
of the like
so this is kind of the setup for the
question my question is
is that uh we mentioned uh during the
talk that if china wants to be a world
power or leading power chinese needs to
do whatever or
and my question is is
is our assumption that china wants to be
a world power correct
um just from a historical perspective
china has always been known by itself as
the middle kingdom the center of the
world
so does it necessarily care that it's
the the a world power
does china's uh projections of power in
africa does is that
more of just a a need for natural
resources or
as it can be interpreted as
a
kind of an expansion of of power because
i want to take a step back
when
in the ming dynasty
there was an admiral admoha and he was
able to
uh put together a huge uh
naval armada that traversed a lot of the
world and
unlike
western powers the ming dynasty emperor
said this mission is too expensive i
don't want to project the power
so i guess my question i'm going to just
tailor it is
should we look at china from the
perspective of the west and if we can't
how should we look at china in terms of
its policies
okay i'll take it and then the experts
can speak china is a world power
it's not a question of do they want to
be a world power i mean it is it's a
member of the security council has been
for 35 years uh it's the number one
economy i read today not the number two
but it certainly will be number one very
soon if it's not this week by the end of
the year by the end of the year okay um
so i think this is a global power and if
we want to go back to the ming uh we can
talk about china was the biggest i mean
in the pre-modern world china was a
global power it had
all the trappings of global power in a
way that uh non-nation states in europe
didn't have and of course north america
had no nation state so um i'm not quite
sure what the ming dynasty has to do
with it except to artic and emphasize
that this is the longest continuous
national bureaucracy in human history
and
the period in which
they were
closed in a way from 40 52 let's say
until 80 was quite aberrant yeah
i
i hear what you say i think it's a very
interesting topic to make a comparison
between you know today's china and the
ming dynasty you probably know there's a
book called the one is
written by our historically the the
insignificant year you know
dynasty
one thing is for sure there there's
certainly a very
clear similarity which is about
corruption
the corruption is like a huge problem
for the ming dynasty and i understand
even inside the government in the ming
dynasty there are also a lot of
political struggles which is exactly
what is happening right now you know in
beijing inside jongdang high i believe
so you know given the news we've already
seen you know about the boshilai
joyounka extraction extract so
that's one point and i agree with
professor davis you know china is you
know it people always try to say you
know the rise of china you know the rise
of china it's not the rise of china it's
the revival of china now back to the
tang dynasty china is already the
leading power in the world but
is uh is china going to be or is is xi
jinping going to make china the
world power i i have some reservation on
that you know in in particular when you
see xi jinping recently they tried to
promote the confucius series you know
you know i hear you say you know the
jungle like middle middle kingdom uh you
can understand you know sort of
literally meaning like the center of the
world but you know the chinese character
also has a lot of confucius meanings it
could be like you know i can be just in
in middle of something you know sort of
a mediator role but not like
the word police or or the what judge
i would say also that in recent years i
think china has also wanted to downplay
its uh global leadership role and
considering itself still a developing
power and so i think in the
currently and in years to come how china
sees and articulates
the form of leadership it wants to play
will tell us a lot about what what it
ends up wanting to do with that power
which is clearly already amassing but i
don't think that that
sense has yet been articulated inside
china
david did you want to speak well i mean
i i agree with everything that's been
said i mean you know china has immense
power and it's going to continue to
accumulate power and the question is how
is it going to use that power and i
think to your previous question i think
you know there are a number of issues
where certainly the us government and
and uh you know people around the world
would like to see china play a more
constructive and more engaged uh
leadership role around the world um
so you know public health being one
climate change being another one of
course when china then does exert its
power you know people in washington
brussels said well that's not exactly
what we had in mind you know slightly
differently so you know you don't really
get one without the other but you know i
think it isn't really a question of it
whether it wants to whether it is and
and to your point about africa as an
example
um you know you can look at this and and
look at you know sort of an
evil imperialist design or aspiration
you can say well you know
you have uh natural resource needs that
uh you know the government is trying to
satisfy on behalf of its citizens and
its companies and
you know whether there's a
you know design behind it or just
necessity
is simply a reflection of the fact that
you know it is a country that whether it
wants to or not you know its actions
have
increasingly global ramifications um you
know there used to be this saying that
when the u.s sneezes the world catches a
cold and it was really a reference about
economic relationships and
you know you can say much the same for
for china um you know in terms of the
implications that developments in china
have for
for economies and and and societies
around the world we don't have any more
questions now in the queue abby from the
gmail so maybe we should see if there's
any last question in the audience
if there's none in the audience
and they're none online then i think we
would thank abby newman and jessica chin
for helping us organizing it and thank
you all for coming